most of us think that when lightning
strikes or waves crash that they do so
even if we're not there to see them yet
according to quantum mechanics the
observer is critical to reality um
Heisenberg even went so far as to say
that in contemporary physics objective
reality has evaporated is the world
independent of the observer or is that
is it an illusion if you're not there or
did Heisenberg and most of quantum
mechanics get it wrong am i right
Chris Timson um Oxford philosopher of
science I think you're head of the
faculty there aren't you to my left
cheerio my letter quantum physicist
again at Oxford University and she's
been pioneering a new fundamental theory
of physics constructor theory which
addresses some of these foundational
issues there are two oft UM Nobel Prize
winning physicist the author of time in
powers of ten and in search of the
ultimate building blocks Chris would you
like to start with telling us whether
reality's there so we take the question
here and is reality necessary to mean
something like to what extent do we as
individuals people like us or creatures
like us with relevant complexity similar
to our own to what extent are we
free-agent able to affect the course of
goings-on in nature or perhaps even help
constitute the course of goings-on in
nature versus everything being fixed up
from time immemorial in intensely
detailed physical laws which constrain
goings-on so I take it that roughly the
the sense of the question the current
question is reality necessary to what
extent are we free within reality to
exercise autonomous causal powers now
with the question of whether and to what
extent we play an active role in
constructing reality today I want to
argue yes I want to take the view of a
particular approach to physics to
quantum physics called quantum Bayesian
ism or cubism for short and try and help
explain to you how Cubist's quantum
basin's contract learning into Cubist's
QB IST and how the Cubist's would answer
positively the question do we play an
active role in constructing reality now
so so far as that is the
that reality is not necessary we are
doing something interesting and
interestingly different from how normal
physics our classical physics would
allow us to be doing but with the
question of constructing I want to lay
down some distinctions to begin with we
might find helpful as we go through so
it seems to me that there are these
three different notions of constructing
reality we ought to be interested in
here maybe there are more but at least
these three will be useful to bear in
mind so I think we need to distinguish
between causal constructing of reality
between constitutive constructing of
reality and but and finally conceptual
construction of reality so the the first
of these the causal construction of
reality is a very humdrum notion that's
the way in which any object which is
capable of doing things makes a
difference the world in virtue of its
being there so in the same way that one
might construct a house by moving around
bricks and mortar and glass and cement
and so on one can construct reality by
doing things like moving around bricks
and mortar and glass and cement so it's
just the humble idea of our making or
their being
causal differences in the world in
virtue a certain objects being there if
I weren't here if you weren't there if
various of us went here if the tent
wasn't here then certainly if we were
here in the tent wasn't here then there
would be a causal difference in the
world we'd all be getting wet thankfully
the tent has been put up so there's been
a difference in and the causal
construction of reality in virtue of
that is that's quite a humble notion
constitutive construction of reality is
a different notion a more metaphysical
one if you will and it's the idea there
being some kind of metaphysical
dependence between kinds of objects so
there might be a something which is
causally independent of me something
which I haven't myself made but
nonetheless which exists and there's a
question of whether or not it such as
this table which I didn't make does this
table exist independently of me that's a
constitutive notion metaphysical notion
and finally conceptual construction
that's to do with our description of the
world to what extent to the concepts
that we deploy in physics or anything
else to what extent are they responsive
to a way that the world is independent
of any process of concept construction
about it any process of the activities
of representing be
now according to the Cubist's
essentially what the action is on the
causal construction of reality and
importantly the difference here from
classical physics is that in classical
physics typically we thought that
insofar as we ourselves as observers
have any role in causally constructing
reality it's a derivative one that's
derived from the completely detailed
completely fixed the term listicle laws
of the universe that have existed
forever or retained forever and our
activities are merely consequences of
initial conditions of the universe and
the changeless laws the Cubist's would
have it that this is wrong
they may exist emergent higher-level
generalizations which describe our
goings on but at the fundamental
microscopic level there simply aren't
any laws there and that crucially for
the quantum visions opens up the
possibility of ourselves as agents doing
things autonomously ourselves in the
world in a way which isn't derived from
the laws of nature and I have to stop
you there thank you um Joe would you
like to go next and do we play an active
role in constructing reality I think so
I was bit troubled by the question
because somehow I would like to give a
little bit of a perspective of the
Croesus explanation about all of these
different ways of thinking about this
question a perspective on how a
physicist would would would consider
this question about reality so it's a
bit like you know you you're faced with
a tiger Tiger shows up and and yeah of
course you could wonder is this real but
you don't want to take a chance
and so it's better to think fast and and
find the problem you have solution to
the problem so try to get out of the way
and and so likewise in in physics the
way I feel about this question is that
really it seems we are facing problems
all the time and these problems
basically gaps in in this conceptual
understanding that Chris was mentioning
of reality and we're trying to solve
them and so in that sense I think we are
constructing something for instance we
were wondering at some point in the past
how come
it looks like stars are moving in the
sky and Sun looks like moving in the sky
etc and we were trying to feed that into
our understanding that maybe the earth
was was was at the center of everything
and that didn't work at some point so
that was a problems like the tiger so
the question of whether reality is
really out there is somehow secondary in
this context because what we seem to be
worried about is how to solve problems
and the solutions that we come up for
these problems are these theories that
we have about reality quantum theory is
an example there are lots of others and
these theories are something that we
construct so this is kind of every time
someone comes up with a new theory
there's new knowledge in the world and
this is something that we use in order
to make tentative progress and I think
this is for those who like philosophy
this is a bit of the view of karl
popper's now this is possibly I think
the most honest and compatible view of
reality that I see from the point of
view of physics so that's that's my
that's my take on this question okay
general and what do you think yes I like
to state my answer to the first question
right away I say of course not reality
is it's one of the great accomplishments
of science in general that we have
discovered how the reality around us
actually can be explained and how things
behave according to laws of nature but
now of course you have quantum mechanics
and quantum mechanics seems at first
sight to put everything upside down and
say to say that there's vagueness and so
on but I think you have to make a very
clear distinction about about vagueness
of the world that they are seeing around
us and the vagueness in our way of
describing this world so physicists
haven't yet done their job completely
they've only found a partial solution to
the question why are the laws of physics
away their eye on what's happening the
answer is we don't know but the best we
can do is make predictions and our
predict
survey if we you see everyday the
weather forecast in television or
whatever you see that they have certain
percent chance of rain
here's 100 percent chance of rain
normally they say any certain chances of
rain chance of sunshine and so on we are
unsure because our theories are
imperfect of course the idea of the
universe is far too complex to say
things anything better than that
but now I come to a very important point
I say if you believe that the world is
realistic that the laws of nature turn
only about real things happening you
have to take that all the way because
whenever you have discussions about the
subject very often people say yes but
don't we have freewill to do this a free
will to do that when we measure things
as soon as you say that you say wait a
minute free will what free will free
will is also determined by deterministic
laws of nature we don't know those laws
of course we don't be a human we have
all our limitations we can't predict how
fast you are breathing this moment but
it's all fixed by by laws of nature and
we should find our task as physicist it
should be to figure out what these laws
are as accurately as we can today's most
accurate theory is called quantum
mechanics so yes I'm very sorry but
every now and then we can treat these
things with certainty that's because our
models are failing because I'm all very
good and in practice the predictions we
can make are fantastic but they're not
perfect so that you have to take into
account then the question of qubits
theory the question why we even have
cuba's well it just thought tells us how
bad our understanding is we can create
vagueness in a very complicated way and
this complicated vagueness is called
entanglement even that can happen which
means that we still have a long way to
go to understand those deterministic
laws in fact I think we are being misled
by the fantastic features of mathematics
our world is seems to describe a
fantastic mathematical equations
mathematicians can handle this kind of
uncertain
they call these non commuting numbers
and not only that in mathematics we can
describe and dangle states very very
well and also mathematics tells us
there's a fantastic symmetry in this
world our problem is the symmetry is
much too large for instance particles
can only sit in certain orientations
they can only the electron can only have
two orientations in this world that is
very strange because you would think
that you could rotate an electron any
way you like and you get another
rotation how come the particles can only
have two orientations
well that's called symmetry there is
rotation invariance in the world which
is to property of mathematics but it is
not a true property of those realistic
states which we eventually want to
describe again this means there is lots
of work to be done why is this so
important this question because in the
Copenhagen discussions people had at a
time the outcome discussion was don't
ask such silly questions because you
cannot check it experimentally that is
true but that's not a good argument
because you can still still to
investigate realism is very important
for our question of model building our
models of the the world today I
imperfect that's why they come to
mechanical but to improve that we need
to have some leads and one of the leads
that we want to use is suppose the world
is completely realistic what would that
do to the models that we have today how
can we improve our understanding okay so
and I think it's worth just passing a
little bit more on the the role of the
observer because classically what
everyone gets taught is that at the
macro level you sit on the outside of
events you know you don't have any
effect if the table falls off it's not
because you've thought about it it just
happened whereas at the quantum level
that has always appeared to be this the
observer has an effect that when the
observer observes the cat's either dead
or alive but was possibly both up until
then are we are we saying that that view
which goes which is what turned physics
upside down when it
happened that we now say no it's it
that's completely wrong that there is no
magical cat which might be led where it
might be live and you are we saying that
that's wrong now
I think that's where Jared wants to take
yes Jared certainly does Chara I'm not
sure yes but so let's press that
question bit further so on the one hand
you might say yes whatever theories we
have at a given time even if there are a
best established theories the best were
working with you know perhaps there's
some successor theory which will have
some other features than the current
theory we're looking at so that's one
thing that we're being urged to look at
by Jared and it could be that in
whatever the success of theory is its
business as normal with regards to the
status of the observer visa via the rest
of reality it's something like a return
to classical physics well maybe but the
question is on what basis do we make
that judgment and it doesn't seem to me
that things need be like that maybe it'd
be nice if there are so but maybe maybe
we can actually be more excited by what
if you look at the content of many
general claims that would take to hold
given quantum mechanics is predictive
success that in fact a more natural
thing to think is that there isn't any
more fundamental microscopically non
very complete theory to be had what do I
mean by that we have the process of
looking at the general claims made by
quantum mechanics and looking at the
confirmed experimental predictions
formulating a yet more general
theoretical scheme in which these can be
embedded and explained and then drawing
conclusions about what further kinds of
theories could possibly produce the
results that we've seen in experiments
these are called no-go and theorems and
they're go experiments in quantum theory
where you're trying to pin down not
features of quantum mechanics itself but
features of what the world itself needs
to be like in virtue of the predictions
of quantum mechanics being confirmed
experimentally and it seems to me that
the outputs of these theoretical and
experimental results is in many ways
very naturally explained by saying there
isn't a fundamental complete completion
there isn't a fundamental
set of laws at the microscopic level
describing everything which behave in
much the way that physics tradition has
taken it to do and what's the problem
with that so I ask you Jared why the
insistence for for this atavistic notion
of the underlying physics well I find
that alternatives are much worse so I
think the best of all possible worlds
that I can imagine would be a completely
deterministic one and once you say party
deterministic then you fail completely
when you say okay deterministic but in
Bell's famous Gedanken experiment Bob
and Alice still have the free will to
choose their orientations then I say
wait a minute now you're violating
something and now you putting yourself
in a difficult position and if you look
very carefully at the mathematics I
claim that Bell didn't have his
definition of causality correct
so causality to him means that the
future will not affect the past but the
past will affect the future that sounds
reasonable but it isn't in our models
yes but in the world as soon as you
change anything in the present you must
have had that preceded by change in the
past otherwise a change couldn't have
happened so the problem the bellows was
struggling with was that he didn't want
to change the past but it did evolve
change the decisions that Bob let us
make to measure something that is
forbidden and that itself is a very
strange thing that that makes it very
hard for us to make models which show
that so Bell thought because those
arguments those models are impossible
and I can know we haven't searched hard
enough but I don't think they're
impossible so hey you wanted to say that
quantum mechanics may have appeared to
its discoverers and generation of
science after to involve this sort of
randomness if you like but you're saying
they just need to peel back that layer
and underneath there will be some rules
which are deterministic which like rules
up here you have to actively search for
that if you don't do that you'll never
you know you never do such a thing for
instance you're you get string theories
which thing is also fun
the quantum-mechanical so this is why I
have adopts also forestry theories well
you're not there yet
now are you are you finding with this
theory for us well the yeah well there
are lots of things to say so the one
important thing is that we mentioned the
observers now usually there is this
capital letter O in front of observer
which is kind of perhaps misleading in
the sense that as far as I understand
quantum theory is very democratic in
regard to observers that means that
basically if you just consider what
quantum theory tells you about an
electron interacting with another
electron you can in a way describe in
the same way the way an observer such as
a macroscopic observer such as you for
instance interacts with a measuring
instrument which is also microscopic
which then interacts with something
that's less macroscopic and less
macroscopic etc etc up to the point
where you hit the electron so I'm not in
in agreement with this this view that
that kind of singles out observers as as
special entities because it seems to me
that unless you add some postulates on
top of quantum theory itself there isn't
any such distinction within the theory
and it's actually the beauty of the
theory because it leads us to think of
what would happen if an observer such as
you were to be superposed across
different state of for example
consciousness or things like that of
course we can't do that now but it's a
nice thought experiment and it would be
interesting to consider that I just
wanted to say that therefore when we
talk about observers we have to probably
with three of us have different views
about what that means and in my case I
don't regard an observer as an entity
which is that different from an electron
which interacts with some other system
can I ask you because you you've raised
the observer as being important surely
quantum mechanical things were happening
long before humans evolved or were cats
before we came along always not quite
sure if they were alive or dead it's
good so I mean this is this is an
excellent
way of probing exactly this kind of
question about the role of the observer
and so when I was stating the kind of
view the Cubist view that I want to
explore today I did allow that there
could be law like claims generalizations
about macroscopic kinds of objects so
it's only really when you sink down that
quantum effects are becoming very
salient that you begin to lose the laws
that you lose the law like structure
underpinning things and you're left with
a sea of entities having causal powers
modal powers abilities dispositions to
do things but not falling under any
well-organized set of physical laws so
that's consistent with all the
macroscopic stuff dinosaurs and all the
rest of it having existed stars having
existed for an awfully long time because
business as usual for large stuff the
surprise in this approach is that it's
not business as usual when you look at
this small stuff of which the large
stuff is supposed to be made so we can
completely recover our intuitions about
what the structure of the past was like
insofar as we ought to have determinate
intuitions there namely at the level of
the things which are roughly familiar
and relatively directly observable and
relatively directly theorized more big
pretty big stuff but also fairly small
stuff so you should probably able to get
most of biology to come out if you
ignore the details about how chemical
bonding works thank you for that I feel
we should let this good moment to move
on to the second one and why is it that
this theory which everyone has signed up
to for the better part of a century none
of anyone's septs it but nobody had
nobody shares the same fear we've got
many worlds we've got hidden variables
we've got don't ask why is that
I mean it's if if any other theory had
such wildly different interpretations
humble biologists like us would say well
you don't have a theory but you will
think you do it's it's a great theory
that's why it exists you know even
though you have no idea how it works
well so the gestured at this earlier
which is that there's of course there's
a strong sense in which we do know how
it works and there's a lot of if you
like interpretation independent content
in the theory so there's a lot that goes
into say that anything interpretation
okay so there are different ways of in
prettying the theory so there are we've
got the mathematical framework and then
you're asking yourself how are we to
understand this what's the world like if
this is a good mathematical description
of it there's a good deal of the content
of the theory which is insensitive to
what particular philosophy if you like
you take to it and that's most of what
you need for deploying the theory in
most experimental situations not all of
them that's that that's the the
Copenhagen just don't ask it works well
that's right so if you you can still do
your day job as a quantum physicist and
in many other bits of physics too
without doing that so that's why there
is a theory there that's articulated but
of course you can always ask more and
you can say well I see what's what's
really going on here we could ask that
question in classical physics right so
one of the things that's slightly
strange about the debate with quantum
theory is that we forget how weird
classical physics classical physics is
supposed to be non weird classical
physics is deeply deeply weird and it's
an excellent education to think you know
what is a point particle is no such
thing as a point particle yeah that's
supposed to be what Newtonian physics is
about is it isn't actually the idea of a
point particle literally incoherent and
collapses in Newtonian physics or and
Maxwell you in physics if you push it
too hard so these kinds of questions
arrive in any bit of physics in fact
many bits of science more generally you
can always ask what's going on here as
well as having the day to day practice
of deploying the theory in very skilled
ways it's just that we haven't had a
successor theory in the last 100 years
which has made us stop asking these
kinds of questions about quantum theory
and it's a theory where it's hard to
push it to levels where it's easy to see
where some of these different
philosophical points of view would make
an experimental difference so such
things are possible in to exist but it's
an experimental challenge some are very
distant challenges some more nearby to
to push things into a realm where we can
look at that so this is this is richness
rather than poverty of understanding
okay yeah I was just wanted to say that
the I think one of the reasons why this
is happening is that all of the existing
interpretations agree on what is
accessing accessible through experiments
at this time so you know what what our
technology can experimental II probe the
predictions of all these there is ways
of looking at quantum theory are the
same and they ought to be the same
because otherwise it would not be
quantum theory it would be a different
theory there are proposals for a
different theory so there are these
models are called collapse models where
the idea is that there is a specific
scale at which quantum theory fails so
those can be tested against quantum
theory and you know we are getting
closer and closer to testing them at
larger and larger scales however as far
as interpretations go given that their
interpretations can be tested with
respect to one another so that's
possibly one of the reasons why this is
happening and it's connected to a
particular feature of the theory which
is that unlike classical physics and as
perhaps while we are not wondering about
classical physics as much unlike
classical physics what quantum theory
says is that there are features of a
physical system that can be accessed
just by looking at it once so what you
can do is that you can prepare systems
lots of copies in the same state and do
lots of experiments the same to figure
out what's going on and get a an overall
picture and the complete picture but if
you just limit yourself to single
measurements on a single system you can
only get some partial information so
there are some empirically inaccessible
features and those are the ones about
which interpretations differ and as far
as I'm concerned I think there was only
one interpretation which is many worlds
but that's just me really here are many
worlds personally well I think that's
the one that makes the most sense it
doesn't make any sense to me but then
yeah because the others are even worse I
have to go with what is that slightly
argument for democracy it doesn't work
bit stupider than the other stuff do you
you obviously don't go for the many
words absolutely not why why not why I
was thinking about the previous question
about there are so many interpretations
and
I think the answer is that the actually
correct interpretation is very difficult
so Einstein was voted on to say that the
dear God is very refined but not
malicious in the mechanics may be very
close should be an exception to this
that the truth is very difficult to to
fathom whereas it's much easier to make
some simplifications which are actually
wrong I had an uncle and famous
theoretical physicist Norland who used
to say that about many things there's
only one truth and there are many lies
so in a democratic world the lie always
win he was not very optimistic about
humanity's future but but I think it
holds it quantum mechanics there's
always something wrong with whoever
comes is the interpretation that there
is not like like saying that simple
reality and that's it and that's the
only one left to me where I can't say
there's something obviously wrong with
it right but I mean I think I'm right in
saying that I'm Stein some people have
said to me I son didn't leave from
quantum mechanics that seems to be silly
I think what he said was quantum
mechanics is obviously true I just don't
think your theories are right so would
he be on your side or would he be closer
to right he just felt that the theory as
Heisenberg and Bohr came up with it was
just obviously not right beautifully
right but he felt that it didn't have
the overall correct theoretical shape
and he was interested in something like
a hidden variable kind of completion but
not of an ordinary kind okay you can't
say hidden variable without telling
people so this is one of the various
interrupts is it fair to say that hidden
variables is making a comeback because
it is a matter of of old fashion I mean
in in in fashion for us as flared
trousers and kipper ties for this lot
it's many-worlds or hidden variables or
is it is hidden variables coming back
and can you tell them what it is I think
it's one of you so you use the word
hidden variables right at the beginning
when I was explaining what it was so I'm
just following you leave oh don't blame
me I'm about just right so the idea of a
so-called hidden variable is it and if
you take the normal mathematical
descriptions in quantum mechanics it
doesn't seem to tell you all of the
things you think there might be said
about how the world
and the idea is there might be some
actual variables in the world which
we're not seeing hence hidden which do
fill fill in all the details so there's
no vagueness perhaps because in fact
there's there is a more specific
description that's going on underneath
it's just one that we're ignorant of so
I think it's fair to say that in some
ways Jarrod's
preferred option for a surpassing or
competing quantum theory would be a
species of hidden variable theory but
one which is relaxed about backwards
influence in time is that but in terms
of them making a comeback
well I think with all of these
interpretations collapse hidden
variables were actually there are
probably increasing numbers of adherents
of all of them because we're actually
understanding what's involved of them in
them better and in some ways it's quite
good to have a plurality of views you've
got serious people seriously developing
them in both the hidden variables
program and collapse programs you've got
genuine physics to do as well as just
philosophy so you actually have to show
how these things could be completed in
various ways to work in high-energy
physics and so on in particle physics
and whether or not ultimately they're
successful is probably down to whether
or not you can get those kinds of models
to work to build it so it's basically
kind of a physics question not a
philosophy question but I think there's
more of everything and that's surely a
good thing surely
can I try move on to the third theme
which is what would be the consequence
if the hidden variables is right or if
if the collapse is right does it make a
difference in how we see the world and
how we feel we work in it means it's
just a matter of free will order whether
things come and go I think it's
absolutely so the one objection half
against hidden variable theory is its
name I don't think it's the exit
variables are hidden they are just
difficult to see and because 99.9
percent or more of this world is hidden
because we can think of particles
accelerating to much higher energies
than we can ever make and the quantum
states here will be in a party hidden so
but we have no access to that kind of
information so these are variables to
which we have no access today but it
doesn't mean that they're hidden for any
fundamental reason other than saying we
cannot see them because our experiments
are not good enough to do that but then
in the very end I think if we keep this
in mind the theory that that could be
such a thing as hidden variables let's
try to make models we take them into
account in a very natural way then I
think that will be a big advantage and
we have some leads to hold on to to make
our next best series for for a reality
well I still want to push on this
question of so that we can all
understand does the does what we how we
think world work change fundamentally if
you're right I mean does do we all have
to go there's no such thing as free well
or I think the answer is yes not so much
that that you now dealing with quantum
mechanics and and and that the world of
the atoms and the fundamental particles
and the photons will be any difference
no it will be the same world you'll be
talking about but in the very end you'll
have an explanation that's completely
natural in terms of ordinary physical
processes which do not know anything
else quantum mechanics this is fish I
have is that ultimately the laws of
nature that this describes some sort of
theory of everything would be a loss of
nature where the word hilbert space the
word quantum mechanics doesn't occur but
in working out in creation see now what
is the consequence of this theory for
our daily lives we have to switch on
quantum mechanics not as as a belief but
as a mathematical procedure
mathematicians use such procedures or
very long long ago so they were already
working with vectors all the time for
them it's very ordinary to do so for
physics we also want to interpret what
these vectors mean am i saying my claim
is they mean nothing they mean they
display your ignorance but it's much
better because look at that there are 10
to the 4 to a 10 to the 80 or something
protons in the universe who can well I
like how can you ever think that you can
control and understand every single one
of them of course we don't so we have to
make all sorts of approximations which
are statistical of nature and the best
well then discovery is called quantum
mechanics okay can either do either of
you two feel like rescuing our because
if I've understood you right we would
have to say we think we have something
like free will but it's not true
so we're creatures who are automatons in
some respect but programmed think they
have free will
it's that arrival of YouTube in a rescue
us from this because I don't fancy that
really well I'm afraid the question of
free will is actually way above our
heads in the sense that some of you will
pay great no I mean the never mind the
the no what I meant is that the so in
any of these interpretations many worlds
even collapse there is just one at least
in the case of collapse there's just one
path that the universe goes through so
even though if you even if you relaxed
this hidden variable idea and you go
into the collapse interpretation what
happens he said the you know the history
of the universe can be collected into a
sequence of such collapses but just one
trajectory and even though there is some
stochasticity in it that doesn't mean
that necessarily that there is space for
your free will so that also doesn't
necessarily rescue free will but other
reasons you might want to come over to
the Cubist side of things no it's a view
there was a reason we had to do so
there's enough structure and goings on
but there isn't an underlying set of
laws which are determining what you're
doing so in Cubism I mean if one's
worried about the questions of
compatibility between determinism and
freewill or even between the obtaining
of physical law and free will then
cubism gives you a robust way of getting
out of it because you like many other
objects in the world are autonomous and
the possessors of causal power you can
make a difference and you're not just
arriving that difference making from the
laws and initial conditions so there is
genuine scope here for something
different is there is there a cost to
that if I sign up to that because that
sounds great I get to decide where I go
on holiday wasn't predetermined but do I
then have to sign up for that if I close
my eyes you will disappear
I mean that's a good point right so this
comes back to the causal constitutive
business I mentioned earlier so it's not
the case that other things in the world
their essence if you will although their
existence better is constituted by
engagement with me that's not part of
the that the Cubist picture is rather
that and you've got a something which
has its capacities and powers you go to
something else me maybe which has got
its capacities and powers they bump into
each other and react in a certain kind
of way which isn't governed by any
detailed law at the microscopic level
but this thing still exists this thing
still exists and you will still exist if
I close my eyes and stuff my ears you'll
be glad to say so it's not a solid sis
kind of program just the certs that
there are fewer physical laws than you
thought there are and that the physical
laws there are go into less detail than
you thought errors I think that sounded
good please it's just one thing to say
that that it's nice to know that both
the collapse view and the hidden
variable view are somehow conservative
views in the sense that they try to
rescue this classical picture of the
world which is so dear to us because
that's what we see directly and the
reason why I actually I like many worlds
is that it's actually the genuinely
revolutionary a new thing in quantum
mechanics so there is a different come
from from the one of it's just heard
about where theses are betting that the
next theory is going to be even more
wild than quantum theory and it's gonna
surprise us in even more ways so most of
these features that quantum theory can
power such as you know even quantum
computing and so on depend from these
other wild features that more
conservative ways of looking at quantum
theory would like to reduce some classic
ality and I would like that not to be
the case I would actually like to be
that the quantum theory is as well as it
seems to be I'm hoping also the search
for the next year is informed by this
view and that the next year is gonna be
even wilder can I ask one question since
we have a genuine many worlders sitting
with us
[Laughter]
well yesterday was the people who were
who were bothered about just getting one
universe into existence yes and they
were having a lot of difficulty and now
you're telling us you the many world is
that every instant this universe is
branching off lots of other ones yes
right there are lots of other things
that are happening in the universe which
seem very wild but this is lots of lots
of universities well there are lots of
particles in galaxies that are doing
lots of weird weird things and and those
are small numbers compared to the number
of many words because when does it
branch off is it when I have a thought
you have a thought of Hedgehog has a
thought well there are yes not a lot of
branching where are they I think the
sorry oh well this is it's what matters
to a physicist is whether it works for
predicting stuff in a way that produces
the least amount of contradictions and
as far as so you know it's it's a it's
very expenses on universes so the whole
debt is put it once but it it really
works and it removes lots of these
contradictions to come up with other
interpretations so why not it's also
worth bearing in mind the the circle
branching in two distinct worlds or
universes isn't really an act of
creation yes it's just enough toys for
intiation so the fundamental ontology
doesn't have worlds in it at all you've
just got the quantum wave form and
Fieldy thing and then worlds are just
particular kinds of structures within
the quantum wave function anything so
they're not actual world not fundamental
okay I'm not sure I believe you at all
okay much more natural instead of saying
that the universe branch is often too
many other universes and so on to say no
nature only has one solution but our
models of it are imperfect so our
understanding of the universe branches
off you may want to predict the future
that many possible predictions which
might be to like the weather forecasts
so much percent chance of rain so much
chance of sunshine and so on
I'm soft the view weather doesn't branch
at all it's either rain or sunshine but
nothing in between you're from Holland
bound to be in between and I think
that's a great place to end I I know
we've only scratched the surface
dimension that are also loopholes in the
theorems yeah well it just remains for
me to point out the last loophole which
you can close which if you'd help me to
thank our panelists
[Applause]